be on the page
hi you're right on time welcome to
ghostwriter beyond the page i'm dj
mchale your host
i'm an author a filmmaker a book lover
and i wrote one of the books from ghost
writer so i'm really excited about
diving back into the ghostwriter world
and i'm really happy that you're joining
me today on this journey today we are
going down the rabbit hole into alice's
adventures in wonderland and along the
way we're going to find out what donna's
been up to now i understand she's
getting very creative with her writing
and even started her own personal video
diary which sounds pretty cool
i think she's going to be wanting to
write an original story of her own but
it sounds like she may be having a
little bit of trouble getting started
so let's go see how she's doing and
hopefully maybe
a special friend will come along to give
her a hand
welcome to donna's video diary
so
here's the latest
ever since ghostwriters started
releasing book characters
i've been thinking of writing something
myself
a totally original story by yours truly
but
so far
i've got
nothing
i just can't figure out the best way to
start
this is kind of new territory for me so
i'm a little nervous
curtis is at dad's house and i'm
spending some time at mom's house
i definitely don't hate having my own
room
but i do kind of wish there was someone
i could bounce some ideas around with
maybe
ghostwriter could help me bring my story
to life
actually
that's not a bad idea gw really does
understand stories
hey ghost writer
if you're around and maybe
bored
i would love it if you could help me
write my story
just let me know
well it was a long shot anyway
what
or
i mean
who
looks like ghost writer does want to
help out after all
okay
let me think
who
[Music]
maybe this isn't such a helpful hint
after all
who who
[Music]
who
who what alice
where did you come from
it's so good to see you oh it's so good
to see you too donna
uh so you were asking something
ghost printer must have sent her here to
help
um
actually yes
but first what are you doing oh well i
was trying to figure out how to bring a
little bit of wonderland here to my
sister you know i was really really
struggling when i was lost there and
apparently i'm still struggling with
this whole croquet thing though it is
much easier with a malatin bowl than a
flamingo and hedgehog
anyway um after my whole experience i i
realized i learned a lot about who i am
and who i can't be
so i wanted to share a taste of that
adventure with my sister by throwing her
a surprise tea party and croquet match
with lots of cakes and tarts to eat
oh i really did love all the sweets in
wonderland
so
it sounds like it's important to you to
share what you liked and didn't like
and
what you've been through what makes you
who you are
so
basically your character
yes i i guess you're right
in fact that's one of the reasons why i
want to write my own story and turn it
into a book so i can share my
experiences
which i guess would kind of make me the
main character in it
well anyway i really do have to go but
it was so lovely to talk to you again
donna
thanks alice
good luck
alice definitely figured out a lot about
herself in wonderland
enough to write a book about it with her
as the hero
and if knowing who she is is so
important to her story
maybe ghost writer is trying to tell me
to first come up with my own main
character
alice is definitely the who of her story
so maybe reading more about her again
will help me decide who the who of my
story should be
the tunnel went straight for a long time
and alice could hear the rabbit in the
distance saying oh my ears and whiskers
and i'm so late alice ran faster so fast
that it took her by surprise when the
tunnel floor suddenly dropped away and
she dropped with it
whoosh straight down
falling is usually kind of scary
but this was a very long slow floaty
fall alice was actually quite
comfortable finally she hit the bottom
with a solid thump that didn't hurt a
bit
jumping up alice caught a glimpse of the
rabbit's tail as it turned the corner
she hurried after it into a hallway but
when she got there it was gone
as she tried to figure out what to do
next
alice saw that she was in a room with
many doors of all different sizes and
colors she tried to open them but they
were all locked
so annoying she muttered to herself
since there was no one else to mutter to
she added some extra hard foot stomping
just because she could
that was the kind of thing her sister
would have complained about but serena
wasn't there so alice felt free to stomp
as hard and loud as she wanted to it
wasn't as much fun as she thought it
would be and a tingle at the back of her
neck made her stop and turn around
a pretty little glass table stood in the
middle of the room and a gleaming gold
key sat on top
alice snatched it up and tried it in
each locked door
until she got to the smallest one and
the key fit
alice opened the door
she was too big to fit through so she
bent down to take a peek
and saw the most gorgeous garden she'd
ever seen
rolling hills
sunflowers and waterfalls
if only she could get herself small
enough to fit through that tiny door
there's gotta be a way said alice
shutting the door
because after chasing a talking best
wearing watch holding rabbit down a hole
and finding a gold key
alice figured there's always a way to do
just about anything
oh
hi
nice to see you again
well
i definitely learned a lot about alice
in that chapter
she clearly likes foot stomping and
beautiful gardens
she's also really determined and
resilient
it seems like she'll stop at nothing to
find a way through that door
talk about persistence if i'm right and
ghost fighter is trying to help me
create my main character
i'll need to start with who and what
they are
i'll have to find description words
likes dislikes
strengths weaknesses
and even relationships like alice and
her sister
okay
i've got a lot to think about
but
i know one thing for sure my character
will be super into fashion
i'm starting to feel really good about
this
time to start writing
it looks like donna's finally off to a
good start thanks to all the help she
got from ghost rider
now
when you're writing a story it's it's
really important to come up with an
interesting main character is that
that's who your story is about right and
who is that character what do they like
it's up to you
and when you're working on it
it's a good idea to get those ideas down
in a journal and it doesn't have to be a
fancy fancy journal like this it could
just be a couple of sheets of paper
that's all you need and if you want to
dive deeper into the ghostwriter world
be sure to read
alice's adventures in wonderland
and then be sure to check out the ghost
in wonderland section of the activity
guide
and of course join the rest of the ghost
rider gang on apple tv plus for more
episodes of the show bye-bye